[Music]
in impossible schedule news a minute I
brigade of the barbells OK'd of the
Bobby Mark Wahlberg shared the details
of his daily routine and people are
making fun of it why what is it like
wake up at 1:00 Jill wake up at 1:00
a.m. you know I heard his schedules so
crazy and he's like such a hustler that
I wouldn't be surprised if people are
like that's [ __ ] impossible I thought
it was the opposite I thought it was
like so lazy because now he's done so
much maybe that he can do whatever the
[ __ ] he wants but he's like the rock
though him the rock he's a hustler and
our [ __ ] hustlers does it seem like
he ages at all yeah he's always has that
boyish handsome look Marky Mark yeah it
tastes cocaine really or a schedule like
that I wolf of wallstreet touch it you
know so we'll go through the schedule
typical daily schedules 2:30 a.m. wake
up I'm out God 2:45 a.m. prayer time hmm
I will go back to sleep if the first
thing I did was wake up at 2:00 and I
close my eyes I'll [ __ ] go back there
see immediately dude I tried that once
people were like oh the best time to
meditate is in the morning right I
[ __ ] got into lotus position and
[ __ ] doze hop dude unless he's do a
beat Choi says he wakes up
doesn't line a coke and then prays yeah
oh right 2:30 they're having me Father
thank you for this coke oh yeah amen
yeah and I really embraced for a while
cuz from 245 not until 3:15 does he have
breakfast for 30 minutes he has a lot of
things to say 30 minutes unless there's
a lot of wishes due to like Frank DeWitt
ever since I was little I was like oh
people are like oh I pray for people's
good health and all that stuff and I'm
like man [ __ ] that I'm not wasting my
prayer wishes for you hey can I get a
good grade so my parents don't be my ass
and I treated prayer like you're Santa
Claus I was like can I pray for that
bicycle that I've always wanted all of
my prayers were like that as a kid just
how to properly pray they were just like
make sure you pretty God so what
obviously on my ass for like a sandwich
and a bicycle sandwich I'm sorry I don't
know delicious sound like it delicious I
don't know what kids want sandwiches
juice you are you were a kid inside that
mac and cheese remember I blacked out
that part of my life thirty minutes of
prayer though Jesus hardcore that's
almost corny that's like four songs no
that's 30 minutes is not a long time
some people do that though my mom pays
for like two hours every morning so I
get it who's she talking to and Buddhist
prayer is a lot of it is like chanting
that makes and a lot of bowing and she
so she follows ISM when you're doing the
Rosary that can usually be like the
ritual could take 30 minutes when you've
got a freestyle though that's a 30
minute freak that's left 30 minutes
records freestyle yeah you might be
Catholic actually Boston okay next one
is from 340 to 5:15 a.m. he works out I
believe that a lot of the Hollywood
hustlers and a lot of like successful
people they like to train at 4:00 a.m.
you know what I think they're just so
busy that a lot of them want to get it
out of their day before their family
wakes up so they can get that in and
then when their family wakes up to lock
it cool now I'm time to put my like fit
in this roll aside and now to beat now
time to be daddy or now time to be CEO
and because you're doing so many things
that require so much brainpower like
you're so exhausted at the end of the
end of the day all you want to do is
just not work yeah but he does have a
workout later god damn that's why he has
a six-pack and he's like seven years old
probably and he's [ __ ] mozillian err
yeah so then after his work out at 5:30
he has a post-workout meal and then
that's for like 30 minutes cuz at 6:00
a.m. he showers and then I've 7:30 a.m.
he plays golf at 8:00 a.m. he has a
snack sorry the showers in 6 to 7:30
a.m. that's what he wrote like an hour a
half shower no it's not a shower it's
like to get ready and then to get to the
goal
having clothes okay Oh cuz he starts
golf at seven yeah yeah well he should
have said shower brush teeth do hair
groom put on suit and then go golfing
get in my car get in my car that makes
sense
you lazy mark wall I could do that [ __ ]
twenty minutes mock walk I love that
name
yeah it's a homie mock walk so then 7:30
a.m. golf 8:00 a.m. snack 9:30 a.m. cryo
chamber recovery oh damn Oh interesting
I forgot a sarcophagus apparently he
does that for an hour because at 10:30
is when he has a snack this ballsacks
freeze okay this is like an impossible
schedule cuz they're like there's no way
you're in there for a whole hour
yeah people can only withstand a few
minutes before you die hey but people
also build up to it and you don't know
what his tub temperature is set to it's
like because you know I hate hate hate
the [ __ ] heat and when me and joys to
go to we spa like we would sit there and
within like a minute I'm already sitting
out and I'm like just talking to Joe
like this cuz I can't take it but owning
on the hot tub I'm able to set it to 105
and I could sit in it for like 20 30
minutes now easily hmm
sorry cryogenics that's wild what if he
owns it for an hour like he owns like
the way Joe Rogan has a chamber in his
own house and he does it every day he
can you can build up to it that's the
secret to long life freeze your [ __ ]
year I wonder if you do actually freeze
we're like you're in there and after the
30 minutes you're just like hahaha you
just died like in the middle if you're
having a business phone conversation or
like yes oh I will and someone has to
yawn doesn't even get an assistant but
my shirt has like three like and falls
him out yeah they like let him out of
the chamber really yeah
10:30 a.m. he has a snack at 11:00 and
that's when he has family time meetings
and work calls which people are pointing
out how are you gonna have family time
at 11:00 a.m. if your kids are at school
I mean [ __ ] his wife time
yeah or it could be like they're
homeschooled or it's summer are they
going to private school at 3 p.m. he
picks up his kids from school my seat he
picks up his kids that's what it says he
owns the school because what if that's
the weekend schedule no cuz that's it so
it's like 11:00 a.m. family time
meetings and work calls 1:00 p.m. lunch
2:00 p.m. meetings and work calls 3:00
p.m. pick up kids from school or it
could be he has kids in different age
groups there could be a kid that's three
that's at home he's spending time with
and he's picking up the 14 year old kids
that [ __ ] rich I would be like yo
somebody else do that yes family time
for him that pushes a button to let him
out of his own personal cryo chamber I
would assume that there's a woman that
is well acquainted with your children
they could pick them up a tree a clock
I'm sure if you're a kid though and you
just had a long day he'll know he has
four kids by the way yeah they might be
in different age group so they're all
doing different [ __ ] so then the next
thing after he picks up his kids is a
3:30 snack exhaustion 4:00 p.m. but to
me that's not like him he snacks a lot
yeah 4 p.m. he does the second workout
and then at 5 p.m. he showers 5:30 p.m.
dinner and family time 7:30 p.m. is when
he goes to sleep because he wakes up at
2:30 yeah where does he have time to
film yeah more people were pointing and
what does he have time to spend time
with his kids they were like he doesn't
have time to get woken up by his kids
either there's also a 7 no mention of
wall burgers which is a restaurant chain
that he runs with his brothers there's
no mention of filming or rehearsing I
should probably all autonomous by now
and I'm sure when he has a movie you
know what I think she just changes yeah
I think this fool is trying to show off
he's trying to show how [ __ ] busy is
like just roll all that [ __ ] up yeah it
feels a little it feels a little
grandiose busy I am yeah let me see the
truth I mean you got to think about it
like this so he's sure let's say he's
doing it but then it takes a certain
type of mentality to want to post your
schedule on your Instagram right like
what are you trying to show so is this
surprising Michael
I'll be like I try to wake up at 6:00
but sometimes I [ __ ] schedule it for
6 p.m. on accident sleep through the
damn alarm like the day like today this
is that sounded busy to me just sounds
like he has a lot of activities and then
somewhere within the middle of his day
he answers emails and has meetings for
like four hours
mm-hmm where most people are at work
from 9:00 to 5:00 which sounds like a
crazy so it just sounds like he has a
lot of stuff to do
yeah yeah yeah you're right he's not
doing that much right he's just shifting
his schedule yeah he starts a day at
2:00 it's ridiculous that's the weird
part
it's like wake up pray awesome workout
do golf kid time or family time then
answers emails then goes back to working
out then showers then kicks it with to
spent like it doesn't sound that busy
that's true like he only has like a hour
to of work which is which is awesome
other than that he's like being daddy
taking care of his family but dude you
know what he's having a lot of fun work
so people that are tripping on this
schedule like it ain't that crazy like I
wish I could work out twice a day it
could also be that his working not as
for his Brando which is absolutely
absolutely
early that they're tripping on his
schedule is just how funny the way he
broke it down so people are making their
own schedule a showing for a bring it
yeah it's a new meme I see just like
alright then wake up 3:15 worry about
how I'm going to pay for all this
whatever in the shit's in a snack line
crying in the crunch the cry chamber and
then people are just like writing their
own special area a pot of tea another
pot of tea thank you yeah and then like
wake up prayer exercise shower play
Weezie's I'm gonna demon get the Zen
lunch exercise I could really mark
walberg though like I need to really
[ __ ] step by step or else my mind is
so easily distracted like I had to write
wake up drink water take a piss brush
your teeth like I had to make the step
by step because what will end up
happening is like cool alright I'm up
early know what but what if I watch some
karate videos
you know and then like okay I gotta
brush my teeth oh yeah that's right so I
brush my teeth and I walk outside
without drinking water or like there's
so many things that happen in between or
like I did wake up early but I spent the
first 30 minutes on Twitter so if I
don't put something in and then while I
do that over and over then it becomes my
routine now I just wake up drink water
go there wave myself
P brush my teeth like it's just now in
my brain but like how wonderful is that
when you wake up in the morning and you
get to just sit there and scroll through
you that's a major a minutes oh it's so
good it's the best thing ever that makes
me sad
yeah it's opposite of what we said it's
good for you
but it feels good it's fun it feels like
relaxing I feel like I get up and then
like one thing leads to another
Instagram leads to Twitter leads to
YouTube leads to this and that and then
an hour goes by and I'm like man I said
I wasn't gonna do this anymore
I really I'm like I thought I was gonna
work out mm-hm
you don't get that you like fight with
yourself regret yeah yeah you know
[Music]